when something is escalating and
tensions are rising in a table
yeah you and gilbert are so gifted at
that where you'll just say
one or two things and then everyone's
laughing again
yes yeah move on you'll move on yeah
yeah
um but i know you're very good at that i
can't do it i i ride the wave of tension
i'm like oh it's about to blow it's
about to blow i'm here for it you smile
a lot more
when i feel you're uncomfortable use
fake smiles but it's like this it's this
you can tell what my fake smile is it's
just like this
but i also sometimes forget that that's
what my listening face is
yeah and i hate it because i've seen
myself on camera
and when i'm i'm trying to really fully
listen
and try it's difficult to make me laugh
that's a problem okay
we'll pretend laugh babe like if you're
if you're reading a scene and then you
have to laugh
you do it can you do it
of course yeah you have to do it now
be real real oh then let me try it
on it sounds really bad if i try you
know just
just you know just how do you do it you
think of something that made you laugh
before
okay i'm gonna think of your goat sounds
all right
hold on hold on it's not coming out
hold on a second i'm getting there i'm
getting that gross
maybe if you don't do it right now if i
know if you don't do it right now okay i
feel i feel like
it's something that you can't just do it
that's why it's going to disturb me for
life you do it right now
i'll be honest i don't think i've cause
i've never seen you never never do
anything
you know what she did the other day
though that she did do one
and she did a fake laugh that made me
laugh so hard no no
that wasn't a fake laugh he says what
would i do
so what i said was we were in the
elevator i said what would i do what
would you do
if your son said [ __ ] you mom you know i
mean you're a [ __ ] or whatever what
would you
because you should be strict and this is
what so i say that to me
hey [ __ ] you mom you're a [ __ ]
she did that i did a menacing life a
menacing laugh right
which made me laugh because it didn't
sound like maybe it's not
it wasn't a laugh it wasn't a laugh yeah
yeah i can't do it
you can't have you ever heard me fake
laughs no because i've noticed when
people will say something funny
that you don't know you do like just
smile and you kind of go like it's kind
of
like
like a polite thing yeah but you don't
let when you laugh baby you don't laugh
laugh like we laugh no you make me laugh
no but
on this podcast i've seen her laugh oh
yeah yeah she like breaks down i think
you're i think
to this day my whole life there's no one
wait that's okay so that to me is your
real life is that fake no that's fake
that's right but i've seen you do that
so many times it's always faking
i'm always faking are you
yeah when people when when i do this and
i've noticed a bit when i've guessed
this with kids when guests come out and
i go i put my head up like this
yeah and i laugh sometimes i like it
right i'm not laughing
how do you do it i [ __ ] hate it but i
was no because there's times i've seen
you do the head thing but then you put
your feet up i know that's real
it's not it's not real the feet thing no
the only time the only time i can really
really know when i'm laughing is when i
did the [ __ ] uh
the goat noise and then when she was
laughing and then i started laughing
that was a real laugh
dude yeah but don't tell that to the
guests yeah because i'm still gonna do
it cut this out
no don't cut this out either yeah but
that's just a you know something i have
to learn this year
someone has to teach me how to socially
fake laughs
because in it when i don't my face is
this
just be i feel like just do you because
then people at least know with you it's
like oh okay
i don't like feeling when people's like
i don't want anyone to feel that their
joke fell flat with me
because then it's just weird and it
happens all the time with me because he
he has such a high level of comedy so
when i meet everyday people and they try
to like be funny around me
and i'm just so stone-faced and i'm like
that's not even remotely funny
that's not remotely funny yeah yeah i
love it you're a cyborg
yeah it's funny it's when you know i've
hung out with
the other day i hung out with santino i
hang out with guys you know santino a
lot
eric griffin he doesn't yeah eric makes
you laugh
santino really makes me laugh santino
makes me laugh that's hard
because he's so i love watching santino
talk to other people he doesn't give
anyone any room to say anything and he
just dictates